[Applause]
[Music]
it's a good week for you RPG fans who
like to strategize it's also a good week
if you like to just shoot or slice up
monsters hell it's a good week if you
just like video games and if you don't I
don't know why you're here but maybe I
can change your mind if you just hit
that subscribe button to get new
releases delivered to you every Sunday
for now let's check out some of the
hottest games dropping this week
supergiant games has a great track
record with Bastion and transistor and
now it's changing things up with pyre it
has beautiful art like its predecessors
but with a new strategic three-on-three
battle system if you fall in battle
guess what pyre keeps going anyway with
a branching story that incorporates your
failures and if you get really good at
combat you can challenge a friend in vs.
mode if that all sounds good to you you
can start up pyre on ps4 and PC on
Tuesday July 25th now let's talk about a
different kind of strategy as
fortnight's taglines says you can't just
take shelter here you have to make it
your first priority is to gather rocks
wood metal and all sorts of resources to
build out your home base then the
monsters show up and it's time to defend
what you've built using all sorts of
guns and melee weapons and traps
it's like gears of wars horde mode but
on cartoon steroids that's pretty
fitting since fortnight comes from the
original developer you can get in on the
early access version on PC ps4 and Xbox
one on the 25th it's been four years
since we've gotten a new Pikmin game and
hey Pikmin is shaking things up it
sounds like a bad Zelda joke but this
one takes Pikmin gameplay to the 2d
plane which is a bit ironic since it's
coming to 3ds in any case you have the
usual multicolored Pikmin at your
disposal from the electricity resistant
yellows to the blues that can breathe
underwater
rather than explore a large map you'll
make your way through platforming levels
using the Pikmin to solve puzzles and
move forward Oh Lamar makes his return
on Friday the 28th but that's not the
only 3ds game launching Friday me topia
is finally coming to the west and if
you've never played an RPG before this
is a good place to start the simplified
systems let you control a party of meze
and different roles like Knights and
mages and chefs as you take on quests
and explore if that sounds up your alley
you can pick it up on the 28th and if
you're not sure you can always check out
some sweet game play over on GameSpot
let's finish with something much more
violent the first thing you'll notice
about sundered is its wicked hand-drawn
art but there's a lot more under the
surface here the many caverns take cues
from the metroidvania genre with a dash
of procedural generation which means
you'll be exploring and re exploring
gaining or resisting new eldritch powers
each time there are tons of upgrades to
choose from and they'll definitely come
in handy when you face the massive and
pretty terrifying bosses sundered comes
to ps4 and PC on the 28th and those are
the biggest games we'll be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with more
games next week